Je suis concepteur de jouets,
avec le rêve de créer de nouveaux jouets qui n'ont jamais été vus avant.
Depuis 9 ans, je travaille pour une société de jouets.
Quand j'ai commencé à y travailler,
je proposais de nombreuses nouvelles idées chaque jour.
Cependant, mon patron me demandait toujours
si j'avais des données prouvant que le jouet se vendrait,
et me disait de réfléchir au développement du produit,
après une étude de marché.
J'ai donc analysé l'étude de marché avant de penser au produit.
Cependant, à ce moment-là, je ne pouvais penser à quoi que ce soit de nouveau.
(Rires)
Mes idées n'étaient pas originales.
Je n'avais pas de nouvelles idées et j'en avais marre de réfléchir.
C'était si difficile que je suis devenu mince.
(Rires)
C'est vrai. (Applaudissements)
Vous avez tous probablement vécu des expériences similaires et ressenti cela.
Votre patron est exigeant, les données, compliquées.
Vous en avez marre de réfléchir.
Aujourd'hui, je mets de côté les données.
Créer de nouveaux jouets est mon rêve.
Et maintenant, à la place des données,
pour trouver de nouvelles idées, j'utilise un jeu du nom de Shiritori.
Aujourd'hui, j'aimerais vous présenter cette méthode.
Qu'est Shiritori ? Par exemple :
prenez les mots pomme, éléphant et trompette.
Dans ce jeu, chacun à tour de rôle dit un mot
qui commence avec la dernière lettre du mot précédent.
C'est pareil en japonais et en anglais.
Vous pouvez jouer Shiritori comme vous voulez :
« neko, kora, raibu, burashi » etc. [chat, cola, concert, brosse]
Beaucoup de mots aléatoires sortiront.
Vous forcez ces mots à se lier à votre réflexion et trouvez des idées.
Dans mon cas par exemple, je veux faire des jouets,
donc que pourrait être un jouet chat ?
Un chat qui atterrit après un salto ?
Ou alors un jouet avec du coca ?
Un pistolet en plastique tirant du coca et vous trempe ?
(Rires)
La clé est d'avoir des idées, même les plus ridicules.
Plus vous produisez d'idées, plus vous êtes sûr d'en trouver des bonnes.
Un brosse, par exemple. Pouvons-nous faire un jouet d'une brosse à dent ?
Nous pourrions combiner une brosse à dents et une guitare et --
(Musique) --
vous pouvez jouer en vous brossant les dents.
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Les enfants n'aimant pas se brosser les dents pourraient commencer à aimer.
Pouvons-nous faire un jouet d'un chapeau ?
Quelque chose comme la roulette russe, où chacun à son tour essaye le chapeau,
et puis, quand quelqu'un le met, un alien effrayant sort du dessus
en criant : « Ahh ! »
Y aurait-il une demande pour cela durant les fêtes ?
Des idées qui ne venaient pas pendant que vous fixiez les données, arrivent.
En fait, ce papier à bulles, utilisé pour protéger les objets fragiles,
combiné à un jouet, a fait Mugen Pop Pop,
un jouet où vous pouvez exploser les bulles autant que vous voulez.
Il a connu un grand succès à sa sortie.
Les données n'ont rien à voir avec ce succès.
Même si ce n'est qu'exploser des bulles,
c'est une très bonne façon de tuer le temps,
donc s'il vous plaît faîtes le passer
entre vous aujourd'hui et jouez y.
(Applaudissements)
Vous continuez tout de même à avoir des idées inutiles.
Tout le monde conçoit des idées triviales.
Si vous basez vos idées sur l'analyse de données et savez ce que vous cherchez
à atteindre, vous essayerez trop dur,
et ne produirez pas de nouvelles idées.
Même si votre objectif est clair,
pensez à une idée aussi librement que si vous lanciez des fléchettes à l'aveugle.
Si vous le faîtes, vous viserez pas loin du centre
avec au moins une idée.
C'est cette idée que vous devriez choisir.
Si vous faîtes ainsi, cette idée sera demandée
et, de plus, sera toute nouvelle.
C'est ainsi que je pense aux nouvelles idées.
Cela n'a pas à être Shiritori, il y a de nombreuses méthodes.
Il suffit de prendre des mots aléatoires.
Vous pouvez parcourir un dictionnaire pour les choisir.
Par exemple, vous pourriez prendre deux mots au hasard et en tirer
les résultats ou aller au magasin et lier les noms des produits
avec ce que vous pensez.
Il faut réunir des mots aléatoires,
pas des informations de la catégorie à laquelle vous pensez.
Si vous faîtes cela, les ingrédients pour l'association d'idées sont collectés
et forment des connections qui produiront beaucoup d'idées.
Le plus grand avantage de cette méthode est le flot continu d'images.
Parce que vous pensez à un mot après l'autre,
l'image du mot précédent est toujours avec vous.
Cette image sera mise en lien avec les futurs mots.
Inconsciemment, un concert sera lié à une brosse
et un jeu roulette russe sera lié à un chapeau.
Vous ne le réaliserez pas.
Vous trouverez des idées que vous n'auriez pas eu sinon.
Cette méthode n'est pas que pour les jouets.
Vous pouvez collecter des idées pour des livres, applications, évènements etc.
J'espère que vous essayerez tous cette méthode.
Certains futurs sont nés des données.
Cependant, utilisant ce jeu idiot du nom de Shiritori,
j'ai hâte de voir le futur excitant que vous créerez,
un futur que vous ne pourriez même pas imaginer.
Merci beaucoup.
(Aplpaudissements)